good morning good morning you are
listening to 105.3 today so how can I
help you could I have the egg white
veggie omelette bites okay we got the
egg white bed sheet omelette bites I'll
get the wake up wrap sandwich one wake
up sandwich what kind egg please we can
do that for you do you still have the
toasted almond cold brew what what you
said the toasted almond Cobra yeah for
you I do oat milk please oat milk it's
gonna be 15 41 thank all right see you
soon all right guys if you were anywhere
near Palm Beach hit up the Dunkin Donuts
at 4430 Hypoluxo Road this guy deserves
a race he deserves his own coffee chain
because let me tell you I would travel
to go have coffee with this guy every
day we need more people like this in the
world help me make this go viral and get
this guy the raise he deserves